stiff conference chairs you'll be able
to relax and soak in Ted's unique brand
of brain therapy this year for the first
time we we have another Ted going on
live sharing the same content as us in
Aspen Colorado Ted's content director
Kelly stencil is there and I think by
the miracle of satellite technology we
may be able to see Terra Aspen to Aspen
do we hear you last year's Ted at Aspen
simulcast was a huge crowd pleaser this
year we're going to trade mountains and
snowflakes for windmills and sunshine
host kelly Stetson and Reeves that's me
will introduce live in-person speakers
musicians and comedy as well as the
complete Ted program simulcast live from
Long Beach tedsters at Palm Springs will
interact with the program and often be
the program Ted of Palm Springs events
include a glittering evening at the Palm
Springs Museum of Art at least one
massive pool party and many more casual
gatherings in the cabanas and suites by
the pool come join me my co-host Kelly
and over 400 amazing people for a brain
filling experience you'll never forget
we have a few seats left so register
today at ted.com / Palm Springs